so we have a graph here of the function
f of x and i'm telling you right now
that f of x is going to be an
exponential function it looks like one
but it's even nicer when someone tells
you that
and our goal in this video is to figure
out at what x value so when
when
does
f of x so at what
at what x value is f of x going to be
equal to negative 1
25th and you might be tempted to just
eyeball it over here but when
when f of x is negative 1 25th that's
like right below the x-axis so if i try
to if i tried to eyeball it it would be
very difficult it's very difficult to
tell what value that is it might be it
three it might be at four i am not sure
so instead of actually it looks like
well maybe three well i don't want i
just eyeball it just guess it instead
i'm going to actually find an expression
that defines f of x because they've
given us some information here and then
i can just solve for x so let's do that
well since we know that f of x is an
exponential function we know it's going
to take the form f of x is equal to
our initial value a times our common
ratio r
to the x power
well the initial value is
straightforward enough that's going to
be the the value that the function takes
on when x is equal to zero and you can
even see it here if x is equal to 0 the
r to the x would just be 1 and so f of 0
will just be equal to a
and so what is f of 0
well when x is equal to 0 this
essentially we're saying where does it
intersect where does it intersect the
y-axis we see
f of 0 is negative 25.
so a is going to be negative 25
negative 25. when x is 0 the r to the x
is just 1. so f of 0 is going to be
negative 25 we see that right over there
now to figure out the common ratio
there's a couple of ways you could think
about it the common ratio is the ratio
between
the two
successive
two successive values that are separated
by one what do i mean by that well you
could view it as the ratio between
f of one
and f of zero that's going to be the
common ratio or the ratio between f of
two and f of 1. that is going to be the
common ratio
well lucky for us we know f of 0 is
negative 25
and we know that f of 1
f when x is equal to 1
y or f of x or f of 1 is equal to
negative 5
negative 5. and so just like that we're
able to figure out that our common ratio
r
is negative 5 over negative 25 which is
the same thing as one-fifth divide a
negative by negative you get a positive
so you're going to 5 over 25 which is
one-fifth which is one-fifth so now we
can write
we can write an expression that defines
f of x f of x is going to be equal to
negative 25
times
one-fifth
to
the x power
and so let's go back to our question
when is this going to be equal to
negative 1 25th so when does this equal
to negative 1 25th well let's just set
them equal to each other
so that there's a siren outside i don't
know if you hear it
so negative i'll power through all right
negative so let's see what at what x
value does this expression equal
negative 1 25th
let's see we can
multiply
well actually we want to solve for x so
let's see let's divide both sides by
negative 25 and so we are going to get
one fifth
to the x power
is equal to if we divide both sides by
negative 25 this negative 25 is going to
go away and on the right hand side we're
going to have divided negative by
negative is going to be positive it's
going to be 1 over 625
it's going to be 1 over 625
and 1 5 to the x power this is the same
thing as
1 to the x power
over 5 to the x power is equal to
is equal to 1 over 625
1 over 6
25 well 1 to the x power is just going
to be equal to
it's just going to be equal to 1. so we
could really it doesn't matter that we
have this to the x power over here and
so we can see i thought i was erasing
that with a black color there you go
that's a black color right over there so
we can see that 5 to the x power needs
to be equal to 625.
so let me write that over here 5 whoops
didn't change my color
5 to the x power needs to be equal to
now the best way i could think of doing
this is let's just think about our
powers of 5
so 5 to the first power is 5
5 squared is 25
5 to the third is
5 to the fourth well multiply that by 5
you're going to get 625
so x is going to be 4
is going to be 4 because 5 to the 4th
power is 625
so we can now say that f of 4
f
of 4
is equal to
negative
1 25
is equal to negative 1 25th and once
again you can verify that you can verify
that right over here 1 5
to
one-fifth to the fourth power is going
to be one over 625
25 negative 25 over positive 625 is
going to be negative 1 25th so hopefully
that clears things up a little bit